russian hackers suspected of spying on
u.s government including treasury and
commerce department
russian hacking is likely to become one
of the top intelligence priorities
by the administration okay suspected
russian hackers have infiltrated
several key parts of the us government
including the treasure we know that the
security breaches were so alarming that
they promoted prompted the national
security council to meet saturday
reuters reported and come less than a
week from um
less than a week after national security
agency warned that the russian
state-sponsored actors
were exploiting weak spots in the
computer system used by
u.s federal agencies u.s federal
agencies and minister ministers
uh including treasurer comes and smoking
got it this is much bigger story than
one
single agency a source fillers uh
familiar to with the story told reuters
this is a huge cyber espionage campaign
targeting the us
government and its interests thoughts
worst case scenario i i don't think
there's any way to minimize just how
terrible and serious this is i mean when
you look at i mean they've been inside
their system since march
all right cover and these are the best
hackers in the world okay
so solarwinds you're saying why them
well because look at their clients
uh most of america's fortune 500
companies top 10 u.s telecommunications
providers
all five branches of the us military the
state department
national security agency in the office
of the president of the united states
while we are off worrying about
ourselves and bickering amongst each
other between
republicans democrats and thinking
china's our only enemy russia's sitting
back there
very sly very savvy very smart
looking to destroy us just like some of
these other other countries are
this is huge i would love to know what
they got i i hope we a
retaliate against russia okay if it's
russians that did this we have to
retaliate in some way
they now look i think we probably have
better hackers i mean what we could be
doing to other countries or we might
have some silent threats that we could
shut down your grid in five seconds or
do whatever
i would imagine that and eric you
probably know some of the the tactics of
our
military cyber teams but i'm sure we're
top top shelf
um and i also think this company in
austin texas
needs to have some repercussions solar
winds do you not have anything in place
where you can't tell that half of the
kremlin is inside your system i mean my
god this is horrible
and you know the treasury i mean when
you just think of some of these places
that they've infiltrated it's bad
news yeah the the
this is a major worry i mean we talked
about last week about who's the number
one threat the united states is for sure
it's china
no doubt um economically for sure when
it comes to cyber
look russia don't don't play um and tom
brought up a good point here we are
arguing amongst ourselves the proud boys
versus antifa and the left versus the
right and
trump versus biden but let's not forget
we're all american here
and we have countries around the world
who are definitely
um rooting against the decline of
america and put russia at the top of
that list and put vladimir vladimir
putin
right at the top of the top of the list
with xi jinping right you can put iran
on that list north korean that's less
these hackers don't play and i'd like to
see this is what i talked about earlier
on the show
modern warfare right it's cyber it's bio
warfare
it ain't hot wars anymore um
you're giving me a little smirk what's
this mark do you remember a couple
episodes ago i said
watch how close how how the left and
biden pitch who the next enemy is
and i told you it's going to be russia
what did i tell you
and the attention is going to get away
from you don't remember me saying this i
do
when did i say this okay no no you said
this last episode when did i say this
two weeks ago okay
go ahead kai uh what if what if this is
a chinese hack making it look like
a russian yeah so for me it's so easy to
blame everything on russia the old
chinese hackers
blame it on russia that old move guys it
is so easy to blame everything on russia
russia's such an easy target to
hate putin's so much easier to hate than
china
so much easier to attain china so look
i'm not saying read into it all i'm
saying is i'm not getting emotional
about the story here's what i do know
guess who's hacking into our system they
all are everybody is yes
but who you pitch as the biggest enemy
everybody's hacking you think
china's not hacking into our system are
you kidding me the insiders they have
did you hear about that sex spy that
they have the the lady that you you read
about that right the
i think you even wrote about that right
on vtpos.com yeah there's a sex
by chinese sex spy you want to tell us
hanging out with
eric swalwell but you know yes that's
something different so literally and
she's not the only one they think
there's
hundreds that china has set in here and
it's a brilliant move
they get these uh charismatic beautiful
people that are essentially working for
the the communist party in china
and they send them over here and they
and they infiltrate it they get close to
these politicians they're having a
sexual relationship
they're getting all kinds of dirt
they're currently they're probably
getting access to their computer i mean
you could see how vulnerable these
politicians very effective method about
it yeah
i got to make a phone call there's an
asian lady i've been uh
talking too lately well you can get away
with it because she's not only fans but
you know
the whole thing here with uh this is a
very similar story of red sparrow
yeah okay red sparrow if you've seen the
movie i don't know if you've seen the
movie
enlighten us pat you've never seen a
movie the book have you read the book
it sounds you guys know the story red
sparrow is exactly
what china's now doing that russia used
to do
beautiful russian women who were fully
trained they would come in and they
would go and get into the most powerful
politician's bed and
hey then negotiation is very easy we
have tape we have this we have that if
you don't want it to come out you better
give us this
it's a very very very effective method
because
man's weakness is through his zipper
if you can get in there and get some
videotape and negotiate that through
you know by the way one of the best guys
are doing that is apparently borat
because he knows how to go and get some
other guys and get him to get him on
tape
it's not a hard method to do shout out
to really i had an insurance
did i tell the insurance story about
this one guy that they were fighting for
35 million dollar policy what the other
guy did did i tell you this story or not
yeah i talked about it yeah i think
this is a method that's been going on
i'm just curious to know who they're
going to pitch as the big enemy will it
be russia
for us to be scared well i know would
russia take offense if they're being
blamed for no reason what they're gonna
say it's not
looking or i don't think putin minds
yeah i didn't
probably do it i think putin's the kind
that's like listen keep
you know keep building me up as a big
random it's okay scare the hell out of
everybody with
two things yeah it very well maybe
russia if they're coming out and saying
it so let's just not pin this on china
but one thing i know for sure pat we are
not going to give china a pass on this
show right here
we're going to hold china accountable so
so even though biden may
even though our friend hunter biden may
even though the
uh left-leaning democrats why do you
love china
china what is it with you protecting
china maybe there's this russian china
red sparrow that i'm talking to that has
infiltrated my mind why are you
and my zipper why are you so protective
of china i'm not perspective of china
honestly open it up right now stop it
listen i don't want you to be
isolated by yourself tell us why do you
love china so much
yeah i just i don't have an answer to
that i'm not i do not love china but
i think it is kai with adam's
infatuation with china he's got to be on
the payroll
if china wants to pay me he's like
hollywood trying to try to pay you a
million bucks
paying attention to a thousand dollars
china tried to pay pat 600
to come give a speech well they're going
to give you 300 and they were going to
dedicate 300 in your honor or something
you didn't see the email
so we got on the call were you on the
call when did we talk china yeah i think
i was there you were on the call
so they they gave me six hundred
thousand dollars is what they wanted to
do fly you to china
i fly to china and i hold the check of
300 000
to give to their charity of choice their
charity of choice
their charity of choice so but i keep
300 of it
and i give 300 to them which by the way
i've never heard of anything like that
in my life but then they have you as a
propaganda tool
i mean it's basically i mean you know
the playbook exactly but it works in
hollywood
i mean didn't jack the founder of
alibaba he owns half a hollywood i mean
all
he owns half the studio crow pay for
play look at the nba but you know what
here's the thing about china not to
change the subject too much but they've
had this game plan and they stick with
it i mean they came up with this game
plan decades ago
and we're playing right into their hands
okay question for you if you're watching
this
let's play this card here together okay
if you
think china is the bigger enemy than
russia
put thumbs up if you think russia is the
bigger enemy than china
put thumbs down
you